get ready for GameSpot's best of 2017  this year was jam-packed with amazing  games and starting next week we'll be  highlighting all of our favorites on ps4  Xbox one PC switch VR and mobile  everything kicks off Monday December  11th when we start counting down our 10  favorite games of the year each weekday  and finally revealing our top three  games of the year on December 20th what  will make a list tune in each weekday to  find out in addition to our top 10 will  also be highlighting tons more games  that we love with our category awards so  if we miss your favorite it might just  pop up there we here at GameSpot love  games and our best of 2017 is bound to  have something you love to  it all starts next Monday so we'll see  you there but we know that the game of  the year is dream dead  [Music]